I feel like I have a platonic
relationship with Brian yeah shut up
he's mine is this a new view Feud a
heated conversation is always fun Joy
Behar and Sarah Haynes putting the Hot
and Hot Topics this time discussing if
men and women can really be just friends
with their co-hosts I learned through my
relationship with Floyd that you can't
have a platonic relationship but we also
never had to see each other naked but I
I didn't have that kind of relationship
I feel like I have a platonic
relationship with Brian yeah shut up
he's mine oh and there is no shame in
Joy behar's game
the break before I invited him to take a
sniff of my see if my perfume is holding
up does it is that a platonic thing to
do a romantic thing I mean I'm dead in
the waist down so it doesn't really
matter fun more fun I want more fun yeah
it was all in good fun the latest in a
series of headline grabbing moments from
the Danes of daytime I just feel great
being there if I've been with joy I've
been with sunny I've been with will be
it's it's unreal it always is unreal and
sometimes too real I've always been
someone that feeds off other people's
energy just a couple of weeks ago Sarah
made a not safe for work comment forcing
producers to cut her audio
60 year olds they run marathons
we'll be right back then there was this
moment last week I think you know that
we as a society love to watch stuff to
judge folks yes that's how you know be
you know I've always thought that the
beginning of the downfall of society
was with
um what's the name of that show I always
tell you that
will be kind of sort of slamming the
show's Network because she says American
Idol is the downfall of society for me I
just found it very loud a bit annoying
when I was watching it ABC didn't have
it they have it now it's a different
show it is more it's a very different
show the judges are different with the
people who are coming but when it first
began it was a very different Republican
yes
and ABC knows
that I feel like this I've told them it
had nothing to do with them it had to do
with yourself after all that all we have
to say is keep the Hot Topic hot takes
coming ladies we'll be watching we want
everybody to have a great day take a
little time to enjoy The View
[Music]